e Este sou eu que fiz uma chamada de
FaceTime com os trem da deep web tudo
isto para comprar uma caixa misteriosa
verdadeira é
o Ok como é que eu entrego essa caixa
não sei só gostava de saber se a Caixa
chega mesmo chegar a casa
E aí
e em qualquer coisa ali dentro pessoal
muito branco e
[Música]
o Olá a todos pessoal aqui quem fala é o
Dark sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo eu hoje trago-vos aqui o unboxing
da Caixa misteriosa da deep web Dark web
real Ok Esta é uma das reais espero eu
olha o aspecto disto está incrivelmente
assustador eu estou aqui usar luvas
porque eu não quero arriscar colocar
aqui em ao tóxico em algo que seja um
problema para a minha saúde Ok Bom enfim
Bora lá ver o que é que tem aqui dentro
pessoal já estamos com luvas estamos
aqui com esta câmera com esta câmera
Bora lá ver se eu consigo tomar estudo
Como descer aqui parece muito que já
pegou fogo tem alguma tinta nota-se que
foi pintado Ok ou até mesmo enterrada eu
não faço ideia estas peças aqui as
correntes e o cadeado isto aparenta que
tenha sido o homem da dar que leva o meu
fornecedor que fez Ok eu não tenho a
certeza mas se isto fosse velho estava
completamente enferrujado Então não
parece acho que foi ele que colocou aqui
mas a caixa a caixa está muito sinistra
o comportamento isso aqui também acho
que foi ele que fez eu não faço ideia
Pessoal espero
E aí
a ouvir qualquer coisa mas vamos ignorar
aqui já tem tipo umas marcas aqui na
madeira olha aí como se alguém tivesse
tipo a contar os dias eu não sei está
muito bizarro OK ela vira do outro lado
supostamente ela abre aqui eu consigo
esperar aqui olha aí tem que qualquer
coisa ali dentro pessoal muito grande
tem ali uns buraquinhos eu não sei se é
uma caixa de música Se é uma boneca
vejam como está incrível esta caixa
pessoal tem muitos prédios aqui que
também aparentam ser antigos porque já
tenho aqui algumas marcas Olha aí a
quantidade de pregos que vem aqui ok
então espera lá o que adianta nestas
duas correntes eu gosto tirar daqui
estes pregos eu consigo tirar facilmente
o cadeado mas eu não sei se aqui tá
igual ok Aqui também tem uns pregos e
E aí
é a minha ideia pessoal é começar por
aqui conseguimos pessoal conseguimos é
um ok que foi mais fácil foi bem mais
fácil acho que continua preso Como assim
isso pensei que tava feito de outra
forma a
eu acho que uma boneca
aí você me manda nunca só vou poder
daqui eu tenho um sapato eu vi um sapato
de uma boneca acabou arranjos acabou já
Vou ter amaldiçoado Acabou minha vida já
rezem por mim que eu não sei que vai
acontecer hoje ok Agora eu preciso de
tirar porque se calhar calma der aqui
uma pancada
e olha só Alguém já tentou abrir esta
caixa reparem só como alguém já tentou
abrir o cadeado a pancada reparem que
estas marcas tem que nos fundos também
com certeza foi marcas que de alguém que
tentou arrombar esta caixa
E aí
eu tenho que esta serra Vamos tentar
utilizá-la eu não sei se esta Serra é
forte o suficiente para destruir a
corrente ao próprio cadeado e vamos
testar e
E aí
eu consegui fútil
o almoço abrir o cadeado meu Deus eu sou
muito bom isto reparem só como foi fácil
a gente é colocado vai Tá quente aí
e como é que o cadeado aqueceu fricção
que fala prendo ciência e
G1
e o que é que será que tem aqui dentro
E aí
[Aplausos]
e já está aberta é só levantar o tampo
aí vamos ver aqui juntos pessoal já
deixei o like aqui nesse vídeo Se
quiserem ver mais conteúdo deste tipo Ok
vamos ver se tu que tem aqui dentro me
agrada porque eu paguei bem caro por ela
eu vou te dizer eu paguei 400 tolas Ok
eu paguei 400 novas por esta caixa se
ela tiver aqui uma unha de morcego já
não vale a pena né
o Hulk Cristo uma criança uma boneca
E aí
oi oi
Eu juro que eu tô com medo eu juro que
eu te conheço
e tem bicho aqui será que você gosta vai
ser barata só ai tem sangue não Espécie
a tinta né O que é isto vez que foi foi
um trabalho manual muito bem feito
porque nota-se que não esse sangue ok
nota-se que a tinta Alguém passou aqui o
pincel e tudo mais mas parece muito real
reparem só tá muito real agora é só não
sai tem cabeça eu perdi o teu daqui sob
um corpo tem cabeça
e ela mexeu com ela mexeu olho em seu
olho
Oi Ju que tá ladrar ainda por cima ao
meu Deus tem qualquer coisa aqui dentro
agora fora de brincadeiras está muito
assustador
o craque mesmo da deep web pessoal Será
que o homem da deep web meu fornecedor
comprou este mesmo lá reparem só tem a
cabeça da boneca tem o corpo e tem os
braços eu não percebo Porque é que ela
vai desmembrar assim desta maneira aqui
uma vela ali tem uma vela ali só tô com
medo eu tô com muito medo de Carnes tu
tem que uns buracos eu não sei se esta
boneca tem uma caixa de música por
dentro ou se tem qualquer coisa ali
dentro parece que ela já foi aberto ali
do lado reparem tem um penso qualquer
parece um já foi aberta não é isso
cabelo tá assaltar meu tá muito uma
cabra vejam como está tudo tipo cheio de
sangue supostamente mas ouvir o que a
tinta muito bonito não dá para cabeça
ali tem um fundo de velcro com cola
quente Ok isto parece um vídeo muito
fala está-me a parecer muito real tá
muito assustador mesmo e os braços Ainda
bem que a tocar mais eu vou trocar a tem
que tocar
e é preciso está muito preso calma
sangue
o Calma a gente pega aqui pelo Bracinho
Oi minha boneca assim
e olha isso esta madeira também tá
queimada que só não percebo porque é que
esta boneca tenho todos os pedaços não
suposto e eu eu nem vou eu nem vou
retirar este aqui pessoal eu nem vou
retirar Deste aqui eu vou deixar isso
aqui começar
e eu não consigo tirar o corpo daqui
a minha cabeça
o musicale cheiro Porque como ele mexe
fica com ele mexe
o canal vou tentar segurar aqui pelo
cabelo não sei se isto o meu Deus
empresa Olha isso
e ela é muito uma cabra que não é que
esta vejam Como já Puxaram o cabelo dela
tá toda arrebentada por aí Ela deita e
fecha os olhos e quando levantou os
olhos abrem o que bizarro só comentem aí
se conhece esta boneca de algum lado eu
não sei mas tem espero ter muito antigo
ok itens perto desse tipo dos Anjos sei
lá eu não preciso muito bonecos também
eu vou inventar um pouco assistem tem
Espero ser 250/40 que é muito antiga
mesmo e cheira mal cheira a puxei vamos
cheira mal para caraca então mexer aqui
a bosta de pombo aqui por cima até tá
bonito ó parem como ela está bem suja e
tem aqui umas pestanas que parece que
foi feito com o lápis qualquer não sei e
o batom dela está muito estranho eu não
sei se isto é se isto é uma Make Up
original dela ou se foi alguém que fez
tipo tem arte que alguém pintou os
lábios dela né tá bem gasto ali ou então
é mesmo antiga parece que o cabelo foi
colado Não é pessoal eu não sei não tá
aparecer
a toca o meu vício só não percebo muito
de bonecas portanto alguém especialista
se tiver aí a ver este vídeo se souberem
que boneca é esta se ela tinha alguma
história macabra comentem por favor
porque eu não sei eu vou colocar os meus
vídeos fica aí tem que uns buracos olha
aqui no pescoço dela ter uma corda ela
dobra mesmo ok ok Olha isso
o que é isto uma borracha qualquer
antiga Isto é mesmo ar que será que elas
como é que as muito antigas tá bem gasta
pessoal eu não vou mexer muito nela eu
vou deixar aqui assim ajudem por favor
ajuda-me a investigar boneca é esta ser
uma boneca antiga se não é falar pode
ter vindo e do Brasil pode ter vindo
Portugal pode ter vindo da Europa
qualquer sítio vamos tem que chegar que
boneca é esta ok pessoal eu vou fazer a
minha investigação eu vou fazer a minha
parte Vamos tentar descobrir o que é que
tem aqui vamos descobrir com o que é que
eu estou a brincar porque pode ser algo
sério algo Paranormal mesmo eu não
acredito muito nessas coisas mas de vez
em quando acontecem coisas que não dá
para explicar e uma dessas pode estar
aqui dentro Portanto vamos investigar
primeiro pessoal e fica para um próximo
vídeo a investigação de toda a boneca
juntamente com toda a informação que eu
consegui reunir Ok ajudem por favor
comenta embaixo se souberam modelo da
boneca sobre alguma coisa acerca dela
juntamente com a informação ver tudo que
temos aqui dentro Ok vamos investigar a
boneca ao máximo e saber o que temos
aqui eu vou mostrar a este vídeo também
o homem da deep web vamos ver o que é
que ele sabe acerca disto vamos ver se
ele tem alguma
vou mandar cometem o que é que vocês
acham pessoal fiquem bem e até a próxima
E aí